[Music]
concerns about the coronavirus have
hammered stock markets around the world
the SARS outbreak in 2003 costs the
global economy an estimated 40 billion
dollars now some predict coronavirus
will do even more damage Carter Evans
shows us what may be the first major
sign in the u.s. of the spreading
economic contagion the Port of Los
Angeles is the largest in the United
States
40% of all shipped imports enter the
country here or next door in Long Beach
but now it's unusually quiet normally
Carter you would see about 10 to 12 very
large container ships working here at
the port every day none of that is
happening right now that's right and the
reason is that 40 vessel sailings have
been cancelled thus far we're a leading
indicator for the economy gene seroka is
executive director of the port he says
quarantine Xin China have factories
shutting down fewer products means less
cargo to ship
so this is going to impact everyone yes
it will it's a conversation of national
significance that drop in traffic is
slowing job earnings at the port which
is responsible for more than 10 percent
of employment throughout Southern
California but its impact could be felt
around the country these dividers is
more of an economic disaster Isaac
Larian heads up mga entertainment the
company behind popular toys like brats
and lol surprise dolls so you've got the
number 10 selling toy in the entire
world I have number one and number ten
and number two a number four and they're
also about outfield that by some
estimates China produces 85% of the
world's toys the eighth biggest import
that usually comes through this port but
with their factories only operating at
40 percent capacity
products might start disappearing from
US store shelves if these things doesn't
come under control the next two to three
weeks it is going to affect so whether
is toys others cause
Electronics whether he's up or all of
these things they're going to get
affected
representatives from the automotive
industry and television manufacturers
tell CBS News they're closely monitoring
supply chains while a footwear trade
group says the footwear industry is seen
an impact on supply and sales from the
coronavirus how is this going to impact
your bottom line maybe hundreds of
million multiply that by all the
businesses around the u.s. that rely on
this port and the numbers become
staggering this will be billions of
dollars worth of impact so people can
expect to pay higher prices because of
the inactivity here right now because
the supply is not coming in as fast as
you and I would like to buy our goods
for CBS this morning Carter Evans Los
Angeles CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here with what the
economic impact of the coronavirus could
mean for you good morning Jill we've
seen really a stock market really
unsettled extremely unsettled how
significant is the risk of a recession
right now well you know right now
economists are not calling for a
recession and the OECD said global
growth could actually be cut in half
because of the coronavirus from 2.9
percent to one and a half percent here
in the US I speak to a lot of economists
they say we think growth in the United
States could go from say around 2% to
one and a half percent as is however
they are increasing their odds of a
recession in 2020 to 50/50 and that's a
big jump from where we were just six
weeks all right so that's a big change
companies are going to be adjusted what
a regular people do to prepare well I
think if you look at like what you
really should do right now it's about
those old habits that we want you to
have we want you to try to take any
extra money and put it in a safe place
an emergency reserve fund we've always
talked about six to twelve months of
your living expenses in a safe place if
you are still employed and we still have
a vibrant job market right now we're
gonna get a jobs report out and we're
gonna have good numbers there the thing
is if you still have a job and you've
got cash flow don't go spend it on stuff
necessarily but pay down some debt maybe
you got some credit card debt take care
of yourself build yourself a little
fortress Jill always a voice of reason
Thank You Jill Schlesinger